for no heart border - two borders what
exactly are the government's new brexit
proposals let's take a look through the
details and first off the plan is Great
Britain and Northern Ireland will leave
the EU including the customs union at
the end of the transition period which
as things stand is the first of January
2021 at that stage according to these
plans there be a customs and v80 border
between Northern Ireland and the
Republic Northern Ireland will stay
though in the EU single market for
agriculture and industrial goods all the
way through till 2025 meaning all goods
coming into Northern I'm from the UK
will need to be checked creating a
second regulatory border here in the
Irish Sea so that's two borders one
regulatory border in the Irish Sea where
products stan has made differ one
customs border four tariffs and duties
on the Irish border and every four years
Northern Line it's gonna get opportunity
to choose whether to keep those two
borders or leave the EU completely it
all comes back of course to the backstop
the notorious insurance policy agreed by
the last government to effectively
ensure that if future trade talks failed
the UK would stay in a kind of customs
union with the EU this is the
government's attempt to abolish it but
there are big question marks so the UK
government wants the EU to agree to
these proposals before the transition
period our so-called front stop which
would mean hammering out the technical
details a bit later Boris Johnson today
insisted there won't be any checks at or
near the border however they'll have to
happen somewhere and the EU would also
have to exempt Northern Ireland from its
current customs rules until alternative
arrangements are agreed then there are
problems with the time limit so what
happens if after four years Northern
Ireland decides to leave a single market
completely the new softer border would
harden and we're back to this debate all
over again and that's on top of the fact
that Stillman is currently suspended so
well Boris Johnson says these proposals
were a fair compromise for both sides
he's also clear the only alternative to
them is now No Deal